never has a request to use the bathroom
caused so much havoc last week two black
men were awaiting a meeting at a
Starbucks in Philly they asked to use
the bathroom but they were told no
because it was reserved for customers
and they had bought nothing so they
returned to their seats and because they
purchased nothing they were then asked
to leave
well they didn't in the manager called
9-1-1
i have two gentlemen on my cafe they're
refusing to make a purchase or leave i'm
at the starbucks at eight seasons free
[Applause]
I'll be honest as possible the two men
were arrested but not before it was all
captured on a phone and then it went
viral well soon a Starbucks boycott
campaign raged across social media
activists rushed to the offending
Starbucks shop and others as well and
hashtags such as Starbucks while black
started trending big time and within a
day Starbucks had apologized and then
two days after the incident the manager
who called 911 no longer with the
company and its founder Howard Schultz
described her this way and I think you
have to say and looking at the tape that
she demonstrated her own level of
unconscious bias and in looking at the
table ask yourself whether or not that
in fact was racial profiling
there's no doubt in my mind the reason
that they were called was because they
were african-american there's a lot we
still don't know and here are some
questions was there a pattern of racial
bias in this Philadelphia Starbucks
where other african-americans treated
unfairly there and did this particular
employee display a pattern or practice
practice of racism in the past or was
she just enforcing company policy by
denying the bathroom to non customers
and trying to stop some loitering that's
also not good for business
well the cold of the cops seems like
overkill but again we don't know the
full story as Starbucks faced these
demonstrations all over the country
there was a rush to judgment and the
company quickly jumped on it and a lot
of people think went overboard rather
than just apologizing and disciplining
an out of line employee Starbucks
announces that it was closing 8,000
stores for one day in May and on that
day they will force 170,000 of its
employees to undergo racial bias
training according to the Washington
Post the sessions will include training
in something you might not know of but
it's called unconscious bias where
apparently you're unaware of your
inherent biases you display no overt
racism but you're biased on the
the training will be guided by wait for
it
former attorney General Eric Holder the
n-double-a-cp and anti-defamation league
officials what could possibly go wrong
holder of course has his own history and
discussing race in things racial we have
always been and we I believe continue to
be in too many ways essentially a nation
of cowards that was how he introduced
himself to the Justice Department when
it became Attorney General by the way
and this is the man who will conduct a
training on race relations of 175,000
employees okay so this is where we are
one employee in Philadelphia calls the
cops on a pair of black men and
employees across the nation are kind of
assumed to be late and racist
Starbucks is one of the most liberal
companies in the world you think Ben and
Jerry's kind of here on the level of
fluffed left-wing Starbucks is up here
look they support Planned Parenthood
they've hired refugees as a protest
against President Trump's policies they
force baristas to address race relations
with customers a few years back remember
they were made to scrawl that hashtag
race together on coffee cups well but if
the coffee chain thought that it was
going to inoculate itself against
liberal ire by being left-leaning
they were wrong there's progressives
supposedly inclusive identity just made
them an easy target for protesters by
the way a comedian I didn't even know
this I thought it was for real earlier
today but a comedian is gonna join us
later he decided to see just how far
liberal guilt would go in Starbucks so
he found his way into a Starbucks and he
demanded reparations how hair gel was
racist so I came to get my own free
coffee
yeah I heard you guys don't like black
people so I wanted to get my Starbucks
reparations voucher
what's that everything it's a real thing
she gives him the coffee I think I
should have just asked for the entire
espresso machine or at least a venti
Frappuccino
yeah whatever you want take it the
question all of this begs is the
following how just is it to subject all
Starbucks employees to the high paid and
doctrine ation of the racism industry
because of the actions of one employee
and will this actually strengthen race
relations or could it actually deepen
division between the races if we're not
careful and if we don't refuse to get
all the facts and if we don't refuse to
be bullied by activists who jump to the
worst motives worst conclusions about
people right off the bat well we may
just end up doing the opposite of what
we want to do we may end up poisoning
the well further in this country and we
may be encouraging more mob takedowns of
well-intentioned people or organizations
or people who just make mistakes and
that's the angle